[Music]
it's time Viktor time you discover the
hero you are
you should probably leave Victor stone
aka cyborg he's a college athlete a
quarterback for Gotham City wasn't an
accident
and was severely injured to save his
life his father merged his body with
advanced alien technology
half-man half-machine but he's all
superhero cyborg is totally unique
I've been doing some tracking what
you're looking for sticking to the dead
soul no no let's gonna do what you do
you can find them use a technopath he's
able to interface with any form of
Technology relax Alfred don't take it
from here do I know you
you can transform its body in a
different weapons we're gonna bring in
the big guns
those are very big guns cyborg is the
perfect combination of the power of
technology and the strength of the human
heart
we need your Viktor maybe you need us be
ready to help save the world
never thought moment you got better
watch out justice is coming
[Music]
I'll take that as a yes what the ring
[Music]
Superman violence acts of war and
terrorism are all on the rise I had a
dream it was the end of the world
you
I think it's something more something
darker
we're asking people we'd unknown to risk
their lives strong man and strong us
alone never heard that it's not a same
that's the opposite of what the saying
is
divided we are not enough
[Music]
worldly soup
[Music]
I made him a promise
why I brought you together
ride ain't over yet man
[Music]
[Music]
Oh awesome as a bad thing oh that's your
oh sorry
it's your signal that means we have to
go now yeah I sort that means it's so
cool
[Music]